يجري رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطريه
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني محادثات
اليوم مع الرئيس الاوكراني بولوديميرا
زينسكي والمسؤولين الاوكرانيين اقد اوضح
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه القطريه ماجد
الانصاري ان الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن
الثاني يناقش في اوكرانيا اليوم ملفات
مهمه واضاف المتحدث باسم الخارجيه في
تصريح لوكاله الانباء القطريه ان زياره
الرئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري تاتي
في اطار جهد دوله قطر للتهدئه ومعالجه
التداعيات الانسانيه للازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه واضاف ان رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري سيبحث مع رئيس الوزراء
ووزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيين سبلات عزيز
العلاقات الثنائيه لا سيما جهود قطرات
تنمويه في اوكرانيا ودعم الجهود الراميه
لتمديد اتفاق الحبوب لتعزيز الامن الغذائي
العالمي